I have to imagine anyone who's working
with you is going to learn a lot about
the history the background the
experimental methods what's so cool
about them why is that such a fun thing
to do in this age of kind of reverence
for Content creation on the internet and
YouTube Tick Tock videos what is the
cinequanon that would attract a
brilliant young graduate student to join
your lab as opposed to become a theorist
or going to work for Google we live in
this age where so much of our
Technologies like black box and visible
if you can even code you're like one
step ahead but to be able to actually
build something with your own hands lets
you experience the world in a way that
you otherwise can't see and experience
and then the added bonus in my group is
to then do something with that knowledge
go back to the drawing board and design
instruments and experiments which can
actually make a difference to people's
lives in the real world as well as make
a difference potentially to the next
generation of hadron colliders or
particle physics experiments
foreign